when i look through the lens i feel like
i'm in a whole new universe having a
camera kind of i don't know it makes me
different than other people you know
getting that picture is like you can't
fake that expression you can't fake that
emotion
you know what i mean like that's why
that's why i'm there i say you know what
i mean way too much
it's for the yearbook it's really hard
studying for the sat because you have so
many things to do you're not going to
get better in one setting you kind of
have to be immersed in it you have to
use that experience that you gained over
and over and over like you're able to
spot
the quality in something that you do
when you care about it
i i knew like hey this is not good
enough i need to like
get better like just purely out of my
own desire to do good to do well
i'll say how i want to say it no i'm
just kidding i'm joking
[Music]
you